welcome to the the sixth
of this this lecture series on
existentialist thinkers
um today we're looking at at lev chest
off and he's a very obscure
thinker who doesn't get a lot of
representation
um but he was very important in the
existentialist movement he was really
one of the second generation of
the you know the entire movement
and one of the people who sort of brings
together these threads so that
later on people like sartre and marcel
can say hey there's a
movement here that we're really the
third generation of
and i guess you know the people that
were bringing existentialism to the
to the states in the 60s and 70s they'd
be like the fourth generation
so this guy is one of the behind the
scenes
figures and he's really interesting
because he goes further in some respects
than than even kierkegaard
but he's more critical than even
nietzsche
and so what i what i usually do with
each of these is i give some
so general remarks and then we um
look at the intellectual biography of
the the person
and then um we look at some of the key
themes
and i usually have i've given you a set
of quotes
from from some of chestop's books about
uh nietzsche and kierkegaard
so we're gonna look at his his take on
them uh and then we do you know
question and answer uh towards the end
but we also do it in the middle if
people you know have a burning desire to
hear about something or if something
needs some clarification
so i've got this uh this quote and it's
not actually by chester
but i think it puts him in perspective
it's by
a polish author um
who was a big fan of chest off and he
wrote to associate chest off with a
transitory phase of existentialism would
be to diminish his stature
few writers of any time could match his
daring even insolence
in raising the naughty child's questions
that's kind of a nice way to put it the
naughty child's questions
which always have the power to throw
philosophers into a panic
for that reason such questions have been
wrapped in highly professional technical
terms
and thereby neutralized perhaps chest of
exemplifies the advantages of russia's
cultural time lag
no centuries of scholastic theology and
philosophy in the past
no university philosophy to speak of but
on the other hand a lot of people
philosophizing
and passionate passionately at that on
their own he was a well-educated man but
he lacked the polite indoctrination
one received at western european
universities it was the best line
he simply did not care whether he what
he was saying about plato or spinoza
was against the rules of the game that
is indecent it was precisely because of
this freedom
that his thought was a gift to people
who found themselves in desperate
situations
and knew that syntactic cocoons were of
no use anymore
and milosh is actually um an
anti-communist
rider riding in the middle of the cold
war behind the iron curtain
so he sees shasta who himself had to
flee russia
as you might say an intellectual
predecessor and so he's very um
admiring of of him and i think that's
part of what's drawn me to chest off as
well
when you read him and and most of his
texts are available online
very very easily on an angel fire site
when you read him you realize that this
is a guy who has read just about
everybody
and thought hard you know about anybody
from plato all the way to his
contemporaries he writes about
martin buber and heidegger and sartre
uh and and engages them um
but he doesn't he has a sort of sense of
irreverence
it's sort of like you know imagine a
conversation at a bar where you kind of
have to
uh you have to hold your own you have to
prove that you have what it takes
to for people to take you seriously
chef stuff will look at plato and he'll
say well i think you're right about this
but
dead wrong about this stuff and he's not
dismissive either he'll say
i wonder why he was thinking about this
thing maybe it was this and this was
wrong too
and he's got a lot of very strong views
on the entire history of philosophy
but you're willing to hear them because
he says them
in a way that is on the one hand kind of
kind of humble and self-deprecating he's
not claiming that he's smarter than any
of these people
and on the other hand he actually is
in a lot of cases smarter than these
people and it shows through
in what he's saying but he's not going
to come out and say
like like kant would or or hegel he's
not going to like try to impress you
with his understanding of them so i find
that very refreshing
and chestnut is also one of these guys
this is sort of a typical existentialist
philosopher where
he'll he's willing to say look we
philosophize from
where we live the standpoints that we
occupy
if you're not a german you know if you
didn't grow up in the field of german
idealism because you didn't go to the
right universities in germany
not a problem you're going to
philosophize from you know kingston
or woodstock or wherever from where you
are at that point in time the culture
that you inhabit
and that's okay i'm gonna do mine
here and if if you don't like it well
don't read me
and so i like i kind of like that as
well um i brought this book and this
will be sort of a little biographical
note
this is this is my my book um
i'll let you take a look and
i got introduced to chest off in the
research for that book
which happens to be about the 1930s
debates about christian philosophy in
france
so i didn't get introduced to chest off
through existentialism i got introduced
him because he was a person
who took a position during the debates
about christian philosophy and
he took a position that was actually
contrary to most of the other thinkers
in the field
a very extreme position saying that
philosophy and faith
really in most cases have very little in
common
and when you try to mix them together
often you get these hybrids that don't
work very well
and yet what's most important is going
to be have to be informed by faith to
some degree
although there's some insights that are
coming from atheistic thinkers like
nietzsche
that are going to be very valuable as
well and
there's he's only mentioned in a few
passages in there because he
he was only involved in the very end of
the debates
um they they occupied a lot of the
french intellectuals from about 1931 to
36
and he was writing his last work at the
time called athens and jerusalem
instead of athens or jerusalem which you
know philosophy or
religion it's called athens and
jerusalem
and it was coming out in a serial form
in a journal called the review to
metaphysical morale
and so he's you know he's sort of like a
guy who gets in
the conversation at the very end of the
conversation he's got some interesting
things to say
and nobody's listening because the
conversation's coming to an end
so he actually compiles these later on
into
his last major work shortly before he
dies
so um i i so i got interested in
for that reason and then i just kept
reading and reading and reading and i
liked what i saw
so when i when i started putting
together this lecture series i thought
well
he definitely belongs in there
so if you look at his his chronology
i've given you this sort of adam braided
handout about that you see that he's you
know
uh a figure who is straddling the turn
of the century
he is born in 1866 so that means by the
turn of the 20th century he's pretty
mature um
he moves around quite a bit in europe
ends up settling in paris
dies in 38 he has a sort of last hurrah
when his
his speculation and revelation is
published posthumously in 1964.
um but so he's occupying that that that
end of the century world war one all the
way up to world war ii period
and he he's born in kiev he's from a
russian
jewish family and that poses some
problems for him
he occupies a really strange position
when it comes to
christianity this is a little bit of a
digression from from the chronology but
he in his romantic involvements
he first has an affair with a russian
orthodox woman
gets her knocked up she has a son she
actually works at his father's firm
big scandal there and then later on
mary's another russian orthodox woman
has three children with her
and keeps the marriage a secret from his
family for years
because there's this tension between
christianity
and judaism and not just a religious
tension but a cultural tension there
um he is he's a thinker
who says that that the jewish revelation
really matters a lot but he also thinks
that that
christianity contributes some
interesting ideas along the way so it's
not like he's saying
ah just reject that and the the thinkers
that he takes up like kierkegaard and
dostoevsky
kierkegaard is a lutheran dostoevsky is
a russian orthodox thinker
um so the you know they're very um
central to his his work and christianity
itself becomes central to his work so
it's a strange tension there um
he becomes a student uh he goes to kiev
in moscow
he constantly gets in trouble with the
authorities winds up getting kicked out
of various schools
you know he was a you look at his works
he's a really smart guy
um that probably was not endearing him
to his professors
he's irreverent um you can imagine that
he probably
wasn't good at keeping his mouth shut at
the time
um he he goes to
to start studying mathematics and then
decides i'm not interested in that i
want to study law
so he's working on his advanced degree
and he
actually um writes a dissertation and
it's not accepted
because at the time it's considered to
be too
too revolutionary to um
would you say too progressive and russia
at that time was clamping down on
progressive movements the irony is that
later on when the marxists get in charge
he's not progressive enough
so then he carries out his military
service as he had to do back then
and he returns to kiev and he's got this
sort of bifurcated life where he's
helping his father
out with this this business this textile
firm
and at the same time he wants to pursue
an intellectual
uh career where he'd study and be
involved in literary circles and
try to change things and um
you know in his own sort of view make a
difference
um he has a nervous breakdown
and this is a bad thing but it's also a
good thing
because it gets him out of the country
he goes to switzerland which is a
popular
place at the time to send russian
sick people who have a little bit of
money to clinics
a lot of french people did that at the
time as well
and you know to get to switzerland you
got to travel through a couple other
countries
and then when you're on your way back
you get to travel through them as well
so he made full use of that
and and you know he travels around and
checks things out
and he acquires a taste of living abroad
um he meets this woman uh anna um
berezovsky and he marries her and um
he has uh he has some children with with
her and then then he returns to russia
and
the you know during this time he's
actually concealing her from his family
they're living apart and um
you know there's a lot of reasons for
that now he begins publishing
his first book he actually um has to
self-publish
and it's not it's not very uh
well it's not you can't even say that it
was rejected because not enough people
read it to actually have an opinion
about it one way or another
it's it's about shakespeare and this
this guy
george brondes who is a critic of him so
it's not really that original of a work
but then he starts bringing out other
works and notice what his next works are
the good in the teaching of tolstoy and
nietzsche now tolstoy was a major figure
in russia at that time
and nietzsche was you know beginning to
be read
this is around this is 1899. so
nietzsche is catching on largely through
the spoke of arathustra and a few other
things
he's not as big as he will be later on
but he's writing this in russia
and nietzsche is being read more in
other places
so um he's really somebody who's doing
comparative work
that that's quite unusual and he's
contrasting these two figures because
tolstoy represents a kind of idealism
a kind of you know everything works out
in the end
even though things look kind of crappy
here whereas nietzsche is you know
in his own words the guy who
philosophizes with a hammer
you know pure dynamite and he's this
caustic
agent that undermines morality and you
know talking about this sort of stuff
could get you in trouble back then
in russia so he follows this up with
with another
book called dostoevskyamicha and
nietzsche had talked a little bit about
dostoyevsky because he had read some of
dostoyevsky's works
he called dostoevsky a great
psychologist
chefstop is one of the first people to
really see
how connected these these thinkers are
and when we think about the beginning of
existentialism you know
there's three figures that always come
up kierkegaard nietzsche and dostoyevsky
now chest off didn't read kierkegaard
until the 1930s
but he's uh he's exposed to a lot of the
same ideas
and he's bringing together all these
these people
hey catherine could you close that door
um he's bringing together
all these people you know
that that are thinking about the same
sort of ideas and he's noting the
connections between
that's part of why shestop is so
important to the existentialist movement
then he starts publishing some other
works one that gets translated as all
things are possible
but the russian for it would actually
mean an apotheosis of groundlessness
and groundlessness you know meaning like
the the ground the foundation for
everything has fallen away
this is a feeling that a lot of people
have in modernity that
all the old certainties all the things
that we believed in have
have failed us are breaking down
you know more after world war one than
before that but he's writing this around
the turn of the century
and what are we going to do to fix that
are we just going to fall into the abyss
or are we going to just do whatever you
know pleases us
or are we going to try to build
something new up
and you know he realizes that this is a
real
problem soon after that he publishes a
set of essays called penultimate words
that are along the same kind of lines
um then there's a while where he's not
he's not doing a lot of writing
now now he's become a person of interest
within the russian intellectual
community
and they started having debates about
his work and about his thought is this
guy crazy
is this guy a nuisance is he a nihilist
is he the next great thing in philosophy
um and you know that that will keep you
busy
and he's he's um he meets uh
nikolai berdyaf another important
existentialist thinker in russia
um who's sort of a patron of him
eventually he relocates to germany and
then to switzerland he actually meets
tolstoy
for a while didn't didn't apparently go
that well
then he returns to moscow and why does
he return to moscow in 1914 because war
breaks out
and he's you might say behind the lines
his his book that he's working on the
manuscript is confiscated
and he has to sort of read you know
start start again
he goes back to russia russia is in this
horrible war
where everything goes poorly and
the government is revealed as being
totally inept
revolutionary fervor is everywhere some
of it being promoted by german agents
a lot of it promoted by the fact that
things were just in such a turmoil for
so long
and the bolsheviks eventually take power
before that his son is killed and
he doesn't even receive assurance that
his son is killed he just finds out that
he's missing an action
he goes to look for him never finds him
so he's presumed killed
kind of a great tragedy for him you can
imagine too you know he's
he's in his 40s late 40s when he's out
there looking for his son
in this chaos of
pre and post-revolutionary russia
eventually you know the bolsheviks
do consolidate their power and
one of the things that the bolsheviks
did was clamp down on intellectual life
and they like i put in there they they
actually insisted that he needed to add
a chapter to the book that he was
working on
called protest claudia which means the
power of the keys
and they say you need you need a chapter
on marxism why marxism is right
and a lot of people at the time were
receiving requests like this and saying
yeah okay
i can i can work within those confines
um
and shasta said yeah i don't think so
so i'm not sure exactly what the the
scope of this is he might have said
you know i'll consider that and then
start packing
or you might just said forget that i'm
not doing it
and then started packing but he leaves
uh he leaves russia
and and gets out of there and where did
russians typically go
if they could afford to go any place in
europe
paris so he relocates to paris
and paris at that time i mean paris is
still a very important city although
it's been
eclipsed in large degree as an
intellectual center
the time that he's going there paris
really is in many respects one of the
intellectual capitals of the world
and especially since you have all these
immigrants coming from
russia and some of the other eastern
european countries
people saying things i i can't even work
here
i got to get the hell out of here they
gravitate to paris
so he ends up there and he seems to like
it quite a bit
he gets involved in all these french
intellectual circles
some of them immigrate circles of
russians some of them french
thinkers he ends up influencing some
some important french thinkers and he
ends up with a disciple
benjamin fondan who unfortunately dies
in auschwitz
he's a romanian jew another displaced
person one of the things that's kind of
interesting
is i remarked that he has a lot in
common with
with kierkegaard he doesn't actually
find out about kierkegaard until 1928.
he's heard the name
he's heard that he should check him out
and he becomes friends with edwin
husserell who's a important
phenomenological
thinker and whistle says well you really
ought to read this kierkegaard guy
because he's saying a lot of the same
things as you are
so he finally reads him and then he has
one of these oh yeah
this guy and i are like totally on the
same page
kind of moments um he actually even
kierkegaard
he managed to criticize some things in
him as well
but he thinks that that's the thinker
that he has the most affinities with
so it's kind of funny isn't it that it's
not until
it'd be as if i were into aristotle
uh but i only found out about aristotle
10 years before i died
but the entire time i was sort of
replicating stuff that aristotle was
saying
wouldn't that be strange so
um the next couple years are very um
very productive for him he publishes his
protesters clavium
publishes a book called in jobs balances
and then he publishes his book
kierkegaard in the existential
philosophy which is a really important
text
for existentialism and this entire time
he's working on athens and jerusalem
he gets sick and he ends up dying
but shortly before he dies he manages to
finish
athens in jerusalem and he leaves behind
two daughters
um his his pupil fondant who
unfortunately is going to be put into
the prison camps soon after that and a
lasting influence on uh
on french and russian literature
also on some english people he
influenced d.h lawrence
um isaiah berlin some of these
some of these thinkers had read chest
off so
before we go on you have any questions
about his sort of like i always like to
put things into
a chronology because then we know where
the guy fits and
uh so uh who is he closest to in terms
of philosophy kierkegaard
yeah i mean he's he's bringing out
things from
nietzsche so he has a lot in common with
him
um you know another person that that he
mentions a lot and i do think he has a
lot in common with would be
um blaise pascal the uh
the 17th century thinker contemporary
descartes
who is is fairly anti-systematic the way
that that chest off is
uh whose work was never finished his his
passes just a bunch of
you know essays and notes that he left
behind he was going to write the great
book
but he died before he could do it um
you know chestnut is a religious thinker
and a lot of times people want to say
that
look you either pick religion
and then the philosophy has to just
follow like in its train
you know in the middle ages they called
philosophy the handmaiden of theology
or get the religion out of there all
together religion is an impediment
you know it's going to keep you from
being a critical thinker and chestnut
rejects both of those sort of extremes
what he says is more along the lines of
look philosophy is great science is
great technology is great for what it
can do
it always gets a little too big for its
bridges and things that can do more than
it can actually do
so religion is over here and offers
a lot of insights that that could be
incorporated into philosophy but realize
once you start doing that your
philosophy is not going to be
something that would appeal to the
people over here and
um religion is kind of a dangerous thing
to play around with
because like he likes to repeat it's a
it's a terrible thing to fall into the
hands of the living god
right because if you have religion and
it's just something like
you know a set of you know nice
principles like be nice to people and
god helps those who help themselves
which is
you know we were told in ccd that isn't
actually in the bible
and uh those sort of things that's not
really religion that's just sort of
moralizing
and it's not just a bunch of stories you
know that don't have any point about
what joshua did or you know this guy
over here that guy over here
it's stuff that people could find
throughout the centuries they could find
personal
value in that could make sense out of
their
screwed up existence and lies
and not total sense but some sort of
sense so religion
always remains you might say
veiled in mystery for shestop so it's
not like you could you know
make a religion for domini's book that
would be useful for somebody like him
um he publishes athens in jerusalem
is that say um a comparison of say the
greek philosophers and
the christians or what's that so athens
and jerusalem
so tertullian was this uh this uh
church father who actually like became a
heretic later on there's a whole story
there
but um tertullian had had said
athens or jerusalem you got to pick one
or the other
greek philosophy poisonous
get rid of the stuff because you know
just just religion just the bible just
scripture
that's the answer yeah tertilian
actually says
what does athens have to do with
jerusalem right
and so chester he's considering that and
he is considering the greek thinkers
it's like a criticism of many of them
like aristotle for example or epitidus
he's also criticizing the middle ages
where you know we think of that as the
age of faith right but a lot of these
middle
uh medieval thinkers were actually
sort of putting god in a box you might
say not not all of them peter damien
went to the far tertullian extreme and
said
even grammar is a tool of the devil and
you shouldn't even study that
so chef stuff isn't endorsing that
but damian said things like god could
make
things that had occurred in the past not
happen and if you think that doesn't you
know at first that sounds like
that's fine that's just sort of like
angels dancing on the head of the pin
kind of stuff
but it's really important because the
question is
is god bound by necessity is are the
rules of logic
higher than god is god down here
and necessity or fate or whatever it is
that philosophy can reveal to us
reason can reveal to us does that
constrain god
and and the way the medievals handled
this was two different
um equally problematic ways one is to
say
yes and so god can't make things for you
know if you
had a cup of coffee yesterday as part of
your breakfast
that's set for all eternity god himself
can't change that
because it happened and god can't monkey
around with the universe
uh like einstein said god doesn't play
dice with the universe right
um because you know he was gonna call
that into question then
then he could call anything into
question now he can't be sure about
anything
so that's one way to do it you say you
know we can actually know
more about god than god himself can
because we can understand necessity and
we're bound by it but
but so is god so that's good news
the other way is to like shift it back
and say no god
can like do anything that god wants to
do
and like if he wanted to make evil good
and good
evil or say you know suddenly decide
that the sun has to be black and suck
all right into it
he could do that and then the worry is
well
what's going to happen then right i mean
how can we rely on anything
and some people say well then just read
the bible and that'll that'll fix things
but you know the bible is a pretty
ambiguous
document that you can you can make say a
lot of different things so that doesn't
resolve it
and shustop would say look neither of
these is a particularly good resolution
we need athens and jerusalem we need
what's best
in in philosophy uh we also need
religion he's sort of like um are you
familiar with clement of alexandria have
you ever heard of him
clement was another uh church father who
was in alexandria which at that time
would be sort of like
imagine uh new york paris
oxford and and harvard all rolled into
one
it was like the intellectual capital of
the world the library of alexandria
was there and there was this whole
alexandrian school
of theologians and they
they did a lot of really interesting
work
he he said that greek philosophy
was the second old testament
meaning that you know you have the
christian revelation
in the new testament and then you have
all this jewish literature before that
in the old testament that's sort of like
you know leading up to
and illuminating the the new testament
uh clement was willing to say that at
least some of the greek philosophers
were sort of like that they were they
were providing a basis for understanding
what it was that this jesus guy was
talking about because
you know you read the gospels and some
of these things are pretty
paradoxical so
clement was more sanguine about the
possibility of bringing this together
and i think chef stock is kind of like
that
um yeah
should we go on to uh some of the other
stuff sure okay
sure so here's here's a few things that
that he says that i i think are nice
quotes to sort of um
wrap one's head around for what he's
doing he criticizes this guy spinoza
and spinoza was probably the most
rationalist of the rationals he even
frames his works in terms of
mathematical
axioms and postulates and you know
deductions and things like that
and spinoza represents philosophy
sort of almost you might say trying to
turn the human being into technology
something almost like a computer do you
see a mathematician
well it's interesting that you asked
that he was he was actually
a glasses maker and he contributed to
optics to a certain degree
but you know he didn't actually make any
major contributions
in the field unlike um
some of the other guys who we bring
together with them like descartes rene
descartes we get cartesian geometry from
pascal came up with a theory of
probability and
leibniz came up along with newton with
the integral calculus
now spinoza didn't have the resources
that these guys had as a matter of fact
spinoza um got in trouble with both the
christian and the jewish authorities
he uh got himself excommunicated from
the jewish community of amsterdam
it was pretty tough to do at that time
for his philosophy
and he had this incredible faith in
in human reason but he didn't think that
most people exercised it very much
so was his philosophy essentially
godless
oh why he offended the jewish community
godless in a certain way uh it sounds
like a pretty clinical philosophy
it's sort of yeah for us of any you know
religion
so he thought that um
god it god exists and that god is like
the
absolute being of things he called it
substance
and at the same time all the traditional
religious stuff like the ceremonial walk
that's all just you know nonsense that
that people made up for themselves
that that's going to get you in trouble
with with any sort of orthodox community
and we would get to know god through
through the intellect alone essentially
um
and we're all here here's another thing
that got him in trouble too we're all
in effect parts of god so it's a
pantheistic
new point too which doesn't go over very
well with traditional
uh and that's somewhat christian as well
well you know if you think about like
the church being part of the body of
christ yeah
by christ yeah but it doesn't extend to
like us being just
parts of of you know one
vast cosmic god because that would mean
that like this is equally god as as as
we are now what what um
shuffle likes the nose i mean you know
it's kind of funny you
you often read the people you disagree
with over and over again
you know so he did that and he said
spinoza only repeats again and again
um no known reader a no lugare
de testari said intelligent which means
don't laugh don't cry
don't be angry or get upset
just understand now imagine human life
with you know this emotional part
you know laughing crying hating
getting angry loving over here
and then understanding over here
i think it would a lot of us would see
that as not a fully
human life that would be kind of like
turning oneself into a computer
spinoza saw that as the ideal he thought
that that
that sort of understanding would
actually be intellectual love for god
and now it was interesting yeah
and you know we would use we would
probably look at that and say well
you know that's kind of a stunted person
right now think about this in terms of
philosophy
is philosophy just about understanding
just about what the intellect can do
or does philosophy it's gonna if it's
gonna be any good does it have to
try to think about why do we laugh what
do we laugh at what is the funny what is
humor
why do we cry what is it that makes us
sad
if we take that stuff out then
philosophy
becomes kind of abstract
and so you know this this is kind of a
typical existentialist idea that
not only do we have to philosophize from
where we are
we're whole human people and we do laugh
and cry and hate and love
and we need to think just as much about
that as we need to think about plato's
ideas
or about aristotle's logic or about
spinoza's concept of god
so that's kind of a good good you know
quote i think um
which would you rather hear about first
his views on on you know freedom and
creativity or do you like to hear his
critical ideas about
uh necessity and logic and and that sort
of stuff because there's sort of
two sides of the same point um
creativity first
okay so
chestoff thinks that
creative work i was actually just just
repeating this to my wife who sometimes
will teach creative writing he thinks
that a lot of people get creative work
wrong in how they can see that he says
you know they carry out this process of
reasoning
if the creation is so entertaining and
wonderful and
so pleasurable to us you know think
about somebody's writing that we're
reading
oh this is such a great book you know it
must be wonderful for the creator
and he says that's dead rock it's
horrible
you're taking this unshaped material and
you're not sure what to do with it
and it resists you at every every every
opportunity
and you shape it into something and then
you stand back and you're looking at it
and you're not sure what the hell it is
or if it's any good and a lot of times
you have to throw it away
that's what creative activity really is
and he says
in another place uh a man who's who's
beginning to think
um you know we think of it like this is
this process of ascending to the clouds
or something like that right
but really he's someone who's lost his
balance
we begin to think about things deeply
when we run into
the problems of life you know like when
do we think about
what does it mean to die when people die
on us or you know
our kids saying you know why did
so-and-so have to die
and then we you know these sort of
problems
we're always approaching them with not
enough tools
with a bunch of people haven't given us
answers before that we sift around we're
like well i know that one's not right
and this one could be right but i
have to think about this more that's
what what real
philosophy is like and so he says
we know nothing of the ultimate
realities of our existence
nor shall we ever know anything let that
be agreed
what does that mean for us do we then
say oh i can't know anything that's
everything is garbage no because that
would be like taking a
a certain stance too wouldn't it he says
that actually means we're free
this is another typical existentialist
theme freedom it says
it only follows that man is free to
change his conception of the universe as
often as he changes his boots or his
gloves
and that constancy of principle belongs
only
to one's relationships with other people
in order that they may know where
and to what extent they may depend on us
therefore on principle man should
respect order in the external world
and complete chaos in the inner he's
saying it's okay to have
inner chaos that that's part of the
human condition
and you know like think about this is
not a philosophical idea but think about
the function of the tie
this has been pointed out many times by
many thinkers and sort of like
part of the um the professional or
bourgeois uh uniform or costume right
why do men wear ties yeah i mean it
doesn't serve any practical purpose we
don't need them to keep our collars
together anymore
that's one reason they had them
originally you know
yeah um you know we have buttons for
that
a lot of times we don't wear them anyway
because sometimes we want to show you
that we're informal so we don't wear a
tie um
it can just get caught on things it
doesn't actually keep anything warm
because
you know what your sternum uh
so what is what is the point of it well
because other people expect it
and that's okay too so if i'm
um working a a retail job
where uh i'm expected to wear a tie
because it's that kind of place that's
fine it's not expressing my inner
essence or anything like that it's part
of the
the ongoing communication and
expectations
between us
that's the way our ideas are he says we
can change our ideas like that
so when i'm teaching a class for example
on ethics it makes sense for me
you know as a professor when i'm
relating to my young students who are
trying to you know encounter plato or
aristotle or whoever for the first time
that i um you know
i endorse certain ideas that i may not
completely agree with like
i'm big on plato and aristotle i'm not
so big on kant a manual [ __ ]
but when i teach kant i teach kant as if
he's right
because then they can try on the ideas
themselves make sense of them
that's part of the ongoing process you
would say
but in the back of my mind i could be
thinking you know this constant thing
kant is a dummy kant is a dummy i think
the valve
oh yeah absolutely yeah that's martin
buber
somebody that that chest off actually
wrote about
and and met and knew um
yeah it's like that you know uber has
this notion of
the i vow relationship is a bit
different than the i
get relationship if i treat you just as
an object i'm treating you as an
it if i treat you as a person i'm
treating you as a vow
and a vow is different than an object
you know objects can like you know
make demands on me like my clock goes
off
or the phone needs to be charged or if i
run into it you know it's not going to
let me go through it but
human beings are different because they
can make a very different kind of demand
like you can actually the phone will
never actually say hey
what the hell are you talking about you
can ask me that
because you're a human being and i can
ask myself that i can ask you that
there's a whole range of things that are
available in the i
thou relationship and we're always
boober says we're always in danger of
taking the eye down and turning it into
an i
it relationship of objectifying right
so chef would he'd go along with that
and say
ultimately the relationships that really
matter
not only personally but in in terms of
ideas
are personal interactive relationships
so his relationship with somebody like
like plato
is a very personal relationship even
though plato's been dead
you know 2 300 years
um he treats plato as if like i said
he's a guy on the next stool at the bar
that he can harangue and say what do you
mean by this
are you sure about that you know he
opens up the possibility of dialogue
that way
and he offers us that too i mean he's
he's
he's a guy who would be perfectly
willing
to um have you say to him i think you're
full of bs
okay why do you think so so
that goes along with this this freedom
if you're going to grant freedom to
human beings
that has to include the freedom to say
no
i don't buy it i don't accept it and so
he says
let's let's keep on inventing systems
thinking them out
but let's agree not to be cross with
those who don't want to have anything to
do with our systems
really they have a perfect right so if
you are if we want to do
the ist game right let's say you are an
idealist
a meaning that you believe that ideas
have reality
and that the mind is ultimately you know
um
bringing everything together that's
that's the crux of experience
and i am a hardcore materialist um
you know a lot of people say look one of
you has to be right or
you know or both of you are wrong and
you're going to inevitably clash
chef stuff and say well that's you know
that's really up to
them do they have to clash with each
other can't can i be okay with you being
an idealist
that's that's a possibility of my my
freedom
um so then he he ends up this is what we
call a pluralistic
um position and he says um
there's another nice nice quote every
philosophical world conception
starts from some or other solution of
the general problem of human existence
and proceeds from this to direct the
course of human life
in some particular particular direction
or or
another so plato has his problems
one of his problems is actually seeing
his his uh
his teacher socrates unjustly accused
and executed
you know big existential problem there
chest off actually thinks that that is
part of why plato
doesn't do what aristotle does um
that that going through that experience
of seeing the most rational person
get treated in a wholly irrational
manner
you know um descartes has a
whole different set of problems that
he's facing
um chef has other things you and i would
have
have yet other ones and so he says
we don't have the power or the data for
the solution of general problems
we're always sort of coming to the table
too late you know
human beings have been encountering
think about what the big problems are
um kant said that they were things like
what can i know
you know what can i believe is the will
free
you know but what are the things that we
actually run into that make us ask deep
questions why did so-and-so die
you know is that going to happen to me
um
how are things so unfair and yet you
know we still have some notion of
fairness
and does that make any sense
the kids ask that on the playground you
know uh what else
um who should i get involved with
romantically should i marry them
shouldn't i should should i care about
marriage or shouldn't i
what's the purpose of all that um
you know we have all sorts of of big
issues what should i do when my friends
don't like each other
you know do i have to pick one do i have
to like
have some sort of decision procedure i
went through that recently i understand
that
yeah now think about what happens when
you go through something like that right
if you have a problem and it's something
simple like you know
if you have a problem on the iphone you
can go to google and look it up
and somebody probably has figured it out
it might just be downloading any app or
you know
updating the thing or sometimes it's a
simple it guys make fun of us
have you tried turning it on turning it
off and turning it on right
now with human beings and the deep
existential problems that we have
we have a problem right so you have
friends that don't like each other
we've all had that one way or another um
and now you're you know it's particular
and you're faced with it and you're like
what the hell should i do
and you start thinking well there's this
solution here and this solution here and
this solution here
and you're like that one doesn't work
that one doesn't work
and that one doesn't work and that's
what the greeks called aquaria
meaning um not you you know like when
you
go into a canyon and suddenly it closes
off
and there's no way to get anywhere else
you need to get through
but all the ways are blocked now what
the hell do you do
so what do we human beings do like you
know some animals just sit there and go
oh
i guess i'm screwed what do we do
we think or we feel or we ask other
people
and you know we muddle our way through
sometimes we're actually successful in
creating some sort of
you know good response yeah yeah
maybe we can get them talking in the
case of friends or maybe we can't
um but when we're doing that we're doing
something that's very
typically human you know it's often said
human beings are the rational animal
that's part of what it means to be
rational it's not just like doing logic
and you know writing books it's
thinking out concrete problems that are
deep
problems in our lives because
friendships matter right
and how we should educate children
matters
and where you know where the building
fund ought to go
matters so chef thinks that these all
are things that pose problems for us and
he says we don't have the power or the
data for the solution of general
problems
consequently all of our deductions are
arbitrary
we're always sort of like taking a leap
you know
so he says therefore let's cease to
grieve about our difference as an
opinion
let's wish that in the future there
should be many more differences
and much less unanimity there is no
arbitrary truth
it remains to suppose that truth lies in
changeable human tastes and desires
insofar as common social existence
demands it let us try to come to an
understanding
to agree but not one job more so again
that respecting the inner space
and saying yeah okay we can't if you
think that
it's it's okay to torture people we're
going to say you can't do that
you can think it over by yourself over
here and explore it all you like
but you just can't you can't actually do
that
if you think that over here that
everybody should be like uh doing flower
arrangement all the time
you're free to think that too work out
that thought as far as it'll go
just don't impose it on the rest of us
we'll do something in here and what
we're going to do here we're not going
to mistake for being anything more than
just
what works we're not going to
hypostatize it
and say this is the whole universe
right we're not going to like introject
ourselves into
the psyche of this person and say the
outer must look like
the inner must look like the outer so
that we can rely on you
again this is i think why chest off was
popular among
uh writers behind the iron curtain
because they saw that sort of thing
going on um
he he also says something that's really
interesting
about creative
people like in in philosophy says
fathers of great ideas tend to be very
careless about their progeny
giving very little heed to their future
career the offspring of one in the same
philosopher
frequently bears such small resemblance
to one another it's impossible to
discern the family connection meaning
they're all over the map
right conscientious disciples wasting
away under the arduous effort to
discover that which does not exist
are brought to despair of their task
having got an inkling
of the truth concerning their difficulty
they give up the job forever
they cease their attempt at reconciling
glaring contradictions
but then they only insist the harder on
the necessity for studying the
philosophers studying them minutely
circumstantially historically
philologically even so you get plato
scholars i mean if you read plato
you'll be struck by the fact that over
here in this dialogue he's got socrates
saying
x and then over in another dialogue
sooner or later socrates is saying
nope not x and then you'll be like what
wait a second what's going on yeah you
know you're contradicting yourself
and he's he says look you know the
people who are actually
working out ideas they're not as
bothered by
consistency as we take them to be
because that's part of what it means to
be creative
you actually get stuff out there and
then you'll worry about you know tidying
it up later
and if you die before you tidy it up
that's fine you'll have disciples
who are these obsessive types who say it
must all make sense we have to reconcile
all this together
and so either they'll like you know work
and work and work and then turn you into
something you're not
right or they'll say yes these are very
deep problems
we must study them with a very renewed
focus and then you know you kind of lose
sight of the fact that
these guys were actually trying to
respond to life
you know nietzsche was not it's really
funny with nietzsche scholars because
nietzsche is this anti-systematic guy
who's insisting that you know
he not be taken as as just another
systematic philosopher and these
nietzsche scholars out there will try to
come up what's the one basic idea that
everything else revolves around
and or are they they you know i'm just
going to focus on this little bit here
and
they're so different than the guy
they're studying
that you're like why are you even
bothering with them chest off is
is very attuned to that and i'm
actually going to skip over the
discussion about about necessity because
i want to talk a little bit about
nietzsche and kierkegaard i'll just say
this he he thinks that there really is
no
what we would call metaphysical
necessity so
in you know a lot of people assume that
the rules of logic
or scientific method and what science
tells us
or you know experience or some sort of
you know doctor
or dogma out there can give us the
blueprint for reality
and if things don't fit that blueprint
so much the worse for those things they
don't exist they're not real
chest off thinks that's a big leap
first we don't have enough experience to
actually say that
we have any sort of rules that cover
everything
you know we've never observed anything
remotely like that so he's taking off
from david hume
who had said that you know cause and
effect and this idea that we have
that's really based on our habits and
it's kind of a leap that we put out
there into the world
and hume you know shook up a lot of
people
including kant and these positivists who
came later
and they all try to like reassert that
in some way
um so chest off wants to say no it's
it's not it's not um
there isn't necessity and that means
that we're actually free
now does that mean that if i if i drop
this it you know it could float in the
air it could
it's probably not going to should i
should i bet the house on
on it doing that no because most of the
time things will actually
go the way we expect them to but there's
all these little corners
where things don't and especially when
we get into things that matter to us
more than you know the law of gravity
like how i should live my life or what
kind of career should i have
or who should i marry or should i stay
married to them
or how should i treat my kids or
what about my parents all these these
sorts of things
there aren't really a lot of rules for
that there's plenty of rules that people
have given us
but they don't hold with any sort of
necessity so it's up to us to actually
be smarter than the rules
and put them in their place um
so you know i mentioned that that um
he's bringing together uh nietzsche
and and kierkegaard and dostoevsky
and and shustop sees those guys as doing
something kind of similar since we don't
have that much time i'm not going to
read over
these uh these quotes i'll just mention
some of
the points from him he says that so
kierkegaard had this idea that
the philosophy you know would try to
sort of
cover everything and that actually
you know reason and philosophy could
cover just about
everything but there are always these
sort of gaps and those are the gaps in
which the religious
in which god could intrude and that
makes all the difference and the trouble
is that the philosophy
the more rational it is the less it can
see those gaps
and the more rational it becomes the
more and certainly
more inhuman it becomes as it tries to
become more humane
it becomes more and more inhuman
now he criticizes kierkegaard for not
going far enough
in certain respects which is kind of
interesting
um and when we look at dostoyevsky and
nietzsche
um dostoevsky brought up this guy who's
the underground man
and kierkegaard is doing something kind
of similar
in saying you need to be an individual
you need to
come to terms with the fact that the
universe as you try to see it rationally
actually doesn't
fully come together and the most
important things don't fit in there
the underground man is sort of going
along the same lines as
as kierkegaard but taking a somewhat
different direction
the underground man says look you've got
all this progress going on and
you know you're almost at the point
where you can treat a human being
as just like a mechanism that you could
you could govern you know
you could you want me to be happy push
the right button and i'll be happy
but i won't really be happy because it
won't really be
me because part of what it means to be
me
is the ability to actually as he says
you know give a raspberry you know the
bronx cheer
or we might say give the finger to
whatever system
is is out there and if you take that
away from me
even though it's a stupid thing to do
you know even though it doesn't get me
anything you take that away from me
i'm no longer what i was and maybe
that's
really at the the depths of maybe all
this progress
and civilization isn't really
um going to make us as happy as we think
it's really going to prepare
for some cataclysms because human beings
are no more oriented towards universal
harmony
and love than they are towards sadism
and cruelty
we can go either way and if you if you
think that
you can just set up a system that's
going to make everybody nice nice with
each other all the time
you're actually paving the way for them
to find ways to import cruelty into it
now nietzsche um had similar insights
um and they both try to bring about you
know
a sort of a new way of thinking
a new what is it called revaluation of
values
dostoyevsky went through a really
harrowing experience he had been
committed to
sort of progressivism i know do you know
about this he uh
he almost got executed he was involved
in these these uh
these uh progressive circles and it was
at the wrong time
uh right after the revolutions in 1848
it happened
so they rounded him and the circles up
and they
put them you know ready for the firing
squad and at the very last minute
the sentence was commuted to penal
servitude in siberia which is almost
like a death sentence too
and he came back from that and he he
he now had you know lived
some experiences that he hadn't had
quite before
and all the romanticism all the
sentimentalism
at least he thought was going away um
chef thinks that he didn't completely
lose it came back
later on and dostoevsky was
was a he wasn't a conservative but he
wasn't
he wasn't somebody who bought into the
progressive uh
ideas after that and nietzsche is kind
of like that too
um this is something really interesting
that shestown says he says
we've traced the history of the
regeneration of dostoy's
convictions how how did justin arise you
know from
from the ashes and he says basically it
amounts to an attempt to rehabilitate
the rights of the underground man
now if we turn to nietzsche's works
we'll find above all
that though they bear little outward
resemblance to what dostoevsky wrote
they contain definite and clearly
expressed traces of those moods and
experiences
that astonished us in the creative work
of the latter nietzsche too is a
romantic
a transcendental dreamer in youth and
then abandoned
that and he says
to the russian reader nietzsche's matter
is not unusual
we have dostoevsky who speaks as if he
were not the underground man not
the washingtoff not karmazov and who
simulates faith love humility
what have you so that we cannot straight
away reject nietzsche even if we want to
for it would be necessary right after
him to reject dostoyevsky
if we if we want to reject nietzsche
this is a really interesting
paradox because some people say ah you
know
especially a lot of christians
dostoevsky were okay with him because
he's a christian
not nature he's an anti-christian
they're saying look so chestnut is
saying if you're gonna reject nietzsche
you're gonna have to reject dostoyevsky
too and by extension this is he's
writing this in
his early work before he knew
kierkegaard he'd probably say
if you're going to reject nietzsche you
probably also have to reject this
christian guy
kierkegaard over here because he's
saying a lot of the same stuff
they're they're they're you know coming
at it from different angles
but they're criticizing the same sort of
pretensions of culture and society
and philosophy um
so yeah though you know he's
chest off is is in some respects
responsible for
for contributing to seeing these figures
as all part of one movement um
why is he not better known oh so that's
a good question
part of it i would say has to do with
the fact that it's hard to get a beat on
him
in in philosophy particularly
in in
is it okay
yeah real quick let me know sure let me
just say
this time he um
he's anti-systematic so that makes it
difficult to get a beat on him
the other thing is he's he's writing in
that
paris milieu and he was pretty well
known in that
he influences people like georges
bataille
there's people contemporaries that that
know him in that area
but in the english speaking world he
just sort of drops out of the picture
and then when people talk about
existentialism they tell a very
selective story
and he is mentioned in one important
existentialist text camus method
synthesis
but camus actually gets chest off wrong
and dismisses him
so a lot of people would look at that
and they'd say well look kamu already
dealt with him we don't need to read
this guy
let's just read these other people
instead you've only got so much time
and then they read chest off if they if
they do
and they're like this i don't know what
to make of this
and and so you know it's hard to teach
it's hard to
write about he's great as
somebody to have on your shelf as sort
of like a companion somebody who's a
friend
on your philosophical journey but he's
very difficult to fit into
academic philosophy